understand that day is going to be the
first four main lobby of what I'm making
injury on the front side
okay okay yes ma'am
[Music]
yeah
they're upstairs
hey
give me give me three let's get three
Fellowship Hall the end of this college
Fellowship Hall they are they just said
they heard down there and then upstairs
let's go I need three
one more
let's go
Metro Police
[Music]
all right
door door
with me with me
next
[Music]
open it I got it I got it
let's go
just move right cover left hover left
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
take this with me take this
no that's locked take this door
take this door take it
[Music]
it's upstairs it sounds like it's
upstairs
[Music]
all right
push it lpbo
reloading
[Music]
there you go second floor
[Applause]
no locked door where do they go in
first four first four firstly all there
y'all somebody hold there
hit that door
rifle first rifle first blue go go go go
go go go go go go
I'm with you go away
[Applause]
[Music]
hit the stairs no go stairs don't stairs
[Applause]
right right
foreign
[Music]